that's my view on life and love in
general is scarcity is what makes it
more valuable people talk about
immortality
it's you know i would like to be
immortal but it does
it does seem that uh when you let go of
the fightiness of life
i feel like
that
meals and
the experiences you have get devalued
significantly like the longer you live
the less value there are in in infinity
if you live forever i worry that all the
meaning will will dissipate and the same
thing with love a quick criticism of
sort of dating culture and all that kind
of stuff like i haven't uh
had shocking revelation that i've never
been an attended date or any of those
things i i believe that scarcity and
dating and
in interaction is like
intensifies the value of when the
interactions do happen so when like when
love does happen and so in that sense
there's something magical about scarcity
in the more subjective psychological
social world
as well and perhaps money is just
another version of that right it's just
it's all about the stories and ideas we
tell ourselves i think they're actually
more interconnected than you're giving
it credit for right which is
what is money money is time
ultimately right the the pursuit
of the acquisition of money right of
whether it's a currency or true money
is because that should give you more
time
and so one of my favorite movies ever is
uh and it's funny because justin
timberlake is in it uh is this movie
i lose most people at that point
in time in time and basically the
premise of the movie is that uh everyone
has a clock that's embedded into their
arm and so uh if you go to work you
basically put your arm underneath when
you leave and there's time that's
deposited into your clock and if your
clock ever hits all zeros you're dead
you die on the spot and so there's a
number of scenes where people are
basically running you know to get to you
and i give you a little bit more time so
you can get to work on monday and then
you work to acquire time and so
basically time becomes this currency
but what becomes very fascinating about
it is there are sections in society
where literally there's physical places
if you only have let's say 72 hours or
less you're allowed to go to section 1.
section 5 though is because you have
years and years and years on your clock
and in this movie everyone at the age of
25
freezes from a biological aging
standpoint so everyone stays the same
but you may have lived for a thousand
years
and so what becomes so fascinating about
it is that rich people have time
poor people do not have time
and so in it justin timberlake the main
character at one point uh essentially
acquires a bunch of time and he's able
to go to uh one of the higher levels um
and now he's attending all these galas
and you know poker nights and all stuff
and one of the first things that he
learns is that in the lower end of
society everyone is running everywhere
at all times in the movie
because time is so finite and it is so
scarce and so therefore why would i walk
down the street i must run down the
street
in the highest level of society
no one runs anywhere and in fact if you
run
you are seen as lower class yeah
because wealth is time and so that movie
is you know it's got a ton of kind of
things that you can pull out of it but
to me is the perfect epitome of money is
time and so when you start to think
about the
acquisition of money right it goes to
this whole idea of time billionaire and
i know that um there's probably a lot of
people
heard about this already but
if you think of a million seconds it's
about
11 days
a billion seconds is 31 years
and so if i said to somebody
you have to switch lives with warren
buffett
would you do it
some people would say sure that'd be
their initial reaction i said but you
gotta have to be you know 92 years old
is the money worth the lack of time
most people would say no right there's
this guy graham duncan
who really articulated this well um and
ultimately what ends up happening is you
realize time is more valuable than the
money but you you acquire the money to
gain more time and be the reason it's
valuable is because of the scarcity of
time we currently have
the the biology the physics
it means that um this is not just the
narrative we tell ourselves maybe just i
don't know but it feels
like pretty sure we're mortal
and in that sense the scarcity there
gives value to time it's fascinating to
think about all the thought experiments
here
of
if that could actually be on the economy
if you can actually convert time
in a frictionless way to money
well and if you start to pull on this a
little bit and say okay a young person
today let's say somebody in their 20s
has about 2 billion seconds left in
their life right kind of 60 years give
or take based on life expectancy
they
usually
until they start to understand this
concept
think of wealth in dollar terms
but dollars are being devalued and so
you know a million dollars doesn't get
you what it used to get right it's kind
of a an old adage and so what you're
doing is you're pursuing something that
ends up losing value
and so it's the constant rat race it's
how do i constantly try to get more how
do i get more dollars how do i get more
dollars because even if i say to myself
you know i'm gonna retire when i get a
hundred thousand dollars
when i get the hundred thousand dollars
the hundred thousand dollars five years
from now doesn't buy me what i thought
it did so now i need 500 000 or 200 000
or a million or whatever the number is
and so ultimately what ends up occurring
is that the bitcoin community and many
people in kind of this idea of sound
money is you want to be able to acquire
an asset that not only will hold the
value right to store a value over time
but it will actually appreciate over
time
and so when you look at something like
bitcoin against the dollar against other
types of assets all of these assets are
down compared to bitcoin right now some
of that's just in the early days of kind
of the pricing of an asset you go from
very small to something much larger
but now what you start to look at is
well if you have a finite supply of
something
what ends up happening is people begin
to value it more
and so
in a world where dollars are infinite
and other fiat currencies are infinite
bitcoin becomes very very interesting
very special
and something that is very aspirational
and so i think that's where you're
starting to see people say wait a second
this is something where that finite
secure store of value is essential to
wealth generation and preservation over
a long period of time hey you did you
like this video great make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time